the battle for number 10 the main tv
inquisitions now over over half the
conservative membership have actually
voted so what's the state of the race
sky news has teamed up with yougov to
find out and here it is on the basis of
this liz truss will be heading into
downing street on september the 6th she
gets a commanding lead 66
say that they would vote for her 34 say
they would vote for rishi sunak now
that's actually a slight tightening on a
couple of weeks ago but nothing like on
the scale that rishi sunat would need to
overtake liz trust in this contest let's
look at what's happening underneath the
bonnet and those people who have already
voted which is about six and ten 31 say
they voted for rishi sunak 68 say they
voted for liz trust
even bigger lead there for liz trust
what about people that haven't does
rishi sunak have a chance well he
amongst people who haven't yet voted 29
say that they voted for him 44 say they
voted for liz trust but look at this 26
say they don't know that needs over half
of these people to go to rishi sunak's
corner in order for him to have any kind
of chance the numbers just are so
difficult at this stage
but what are the challenges that whoever
takes over will face this poll gave us
some clues the affection that this party
has the conservative party for boris
johnson evident in this we asked what if
boris johnson was actually on the ballot
paper and he wins by a landslide 46
percent say they'd vote for him 24 for
liz trust 23 for rishi sunak this group
of people the conservative party quite
clear they don't think boris johnson
should have been slung out of number 10
at all in this poll
but what of the toxicity of this race
lots of mud slinging but has it
rebounded on the membership well the
answer appears yes for a big minority we
asked whether liz trust should include
richie sudak in her cabinet 52 say yes
but look at this over a third of the
conservative party say that the man that
took the conservative party and the
government and the country through the
pandemic and wanted to be prime minister
should be left out
of the next prime minister's cabinet
that's quite a degree of dislike of
hatred that the next prime minister is
going to have to contend with along with
all the other challenges of the cost of
living crisis i think putting the
conservative party back together is
going to be very difficult for whoever
enters number 10 on september the 6th